They say it's called a
flying bird It
has only one wing and can't fly
unless a male and female pair snuggle up to each other It's an
imperfect creature
But I wonder why
I thought that way of life was
beautiful
[Music]
I
felt beautiful.
[Applause]
I want to take a bath
.
There
is no sea in the 13 cities Sea
I want to swim in the clean
sea Unfortunately there is no sea I can't take a
shower
I feel like swimming
I'll be in effect soon
I don't like it, they say it's a fertile
bird I read in a book long ago that a
male and a female can't even fly unless they're close together A
pitiful creature
[music]
I'm sure it hides itself in the leaves of the trees until it finds one side
Hold your breath and someday
you'll have a dream of flying into the sky
[music]
Hey, where are the birds that couldn't fly to the end?
I know the
answer, the answer is  I found
[music] I
killed my partner, that's why the woman has horns and
fangs The parasite I rode
with sucked my blood, and I'm sure I'll die on the third try.
It's a rumor, but it's true that there
's someone who actually heard the security guard talking.
If you don't want to
refuse, that Hiro,
you
're the kind of Naomi
who got caught up in it, are
n't you?  The seat is too hard for the elderly.Is there
another way?
How are you?
I'm asking him to take care of my children.  There's something about this rapid increase in the
team, and
it may not be
possible for the
Ape old men to
understand it.
I can't find a troubled child
until the end
He's
alive
again There was a place like this Parasite But it's different from our uniform
No way, he's
drowning
I need help
The
first time I saw a woman
naked I couldn't take my eyes off her
[music]
I thought she was dead You're a parasite so why don't
you
bathe in a place like this It
's strange I heard the sea water is salty
This is
n't the sea,
but I'll go out that way But it's
the most sea-
like place I know
I thought you were drowning, so I thought I'd
try to help you,
but
could you put some clothes on?
Thank you,
that uniform
You
're a parasite
too
No, I can't ride, I can't ride
Well, I'm always alone Because of
this
corner You
make your own place
to belong If you can't make a partner
again It's good
[music] It's
a thrilling taste It's a
tingling and you get caught somewhere
Dangerous taste Whatever it is  The kiss was good
Kiss
huh You guys don't know It's something
special I
might be interested in you You
won't be my darling
Hey,
I can pull you out
You were
n't scared when you saw my horns In
the hand that was held out to
me, I
[music]
Sorry,
time's up
It's time to start
Partner, I'm bothering you
Partner,
you're a parasite cadet tomorrow's enlistment ceremony
, aren't you?  It's not a listile that anyone
can handle
Name
Your name is Name We have a
name in
Parasite
[music]
More than the shock of being teased for not having a partner Somewhere in my heart I was still
hoping for something like that I was
miserable and
ashamed that
I
was there I know there's nowhere for a flightless bird to go
[music]
Look at it  Grown-ups, there
's so many of them For us
you're the chosen ones That's what my
daddy said
Ever since
we can remember We've been numbered children And we've got
a pair of men and women who can move them
Weapons called franks
I was taught that my only mission was to ride and fight
Until the last drop of life in the land that burns I
want you to line up with the light of mankind
Children who don't deserve it have no existence worth,
so I'm leaving here  Once
I've decided, focus on the ceremony Papas are watching.
Are you sure you don't intend to stay?
No
Yes
Understood
Positive pulse pin factor decreased
Time out
6th connection start
Measured ability
Negative pulse confirmed
Positive pulse in the atmosphere
321 timed out
Altitude 703 Code 016
Only Hiro  But I wish I could have
stayed, but maybe you're holding back from me No, even if I stay here, it's not going to be of any use to me,
and
Kira was always like that, right?
Didn't you see the friends who disappeared at the facility?
after death  Naomi
[laughter]
Hiro didn't come
.
I'm not going
back I've never heard of a parasite that's
gone back Are you ready?
Naomi I don't
need it anymore so use it with everyone
I'm quite fond of
this name that Hiro gave me
[music]
Find a partner
, even if it's a plant that didn't start in time
[music] It
smells like a dinosaur.
What
did
not happen a moment ago Prepare to intercept
[Applause]
It's a giant dragon General Taihei 59 It's okay to be big and strong I'm still connected Please prepare for evacuation
It's hard to see stamping at a time like this Again, you're an
idiot for throwing things away at an event I don't know which one is the
monster
[Music]
Wait, that's no good Leave
it alone in the
garden
What are you doing there?
You've got to go alone Wait
a
minute You're injured You're a virgin, it's unreasonable And you're not alone
You can't move Franks
alone
I'm going to die I'm not afraid to die One of these days he'll
start moving
If that happens, all the roads will be annihilated
I'm not afraid to die
There are things
I have to do [music] I'm going
I thought that I couldn't save my friends or face a huge dragon But
when I saw her in front of
me For some reason, the words that came out of my mouth
Wait,
I'll ride that robot I
can't leave you
alone  I can't let you go
[music] I'm
prepared to die
I don't know, but
if it's the way it is now,
I have no place to
belong.
I like those eyes, my
heart is pounding
Come on, come on
[music]
I've tasted you,
now you're
my
darling  When these come
together and overlap our hearts,
the maiden of steel reveals its true form
[music]
this is franks, it's a
beautiful stretch, but
who's riding it
[music]
stop it
that's franks
we  Through
the
window of the round robot classroom I
vaguely
touched the heat of my lips for some
reason My heart was pounding I don't remember anything else that happened in the cockpit at that time  But I
'm going to introduce you to my life as a partner I'll introduce you to Ape's
special love unit Pistol Code 002
You're a girl with the blood of a giant dragon